mercedes there are over 70 golf courses
in las vegas making it the perfect place
to pick up the sport and the pga tour
superstore is here to help those
that are new to the game
[Music]
jc no no no no no we want to use this
instead
probably a little bit safer inside a
little bit yeah
june is an extra special month for fans
of the fairway because
june is women's golf month stacey tell
us more
about women's golf day yeah so women's
golf day
is actually we celebrate all of girls
all of women on this special day of
playing golf
now why is it so special to you in the
store so pga tour superstore has
always been a big supporter of women's
golf day and now
we actually get to continue our
relationship
which is so super exciting is becoming
the official retailer of women's soft
day that is fantastic your store is
beautiful and just kind of looking
around
i don't i'm not feeling the right vibe
if he can help me out absolutely let's
go all right let's get some clothes come
[Music]
on
[Music]
bye
[Music]
what do you think oh my gosh you look
amazing i feel fresh like i'm ready to
hit the golf course
i love it absolutely love it and i also
have some women's golf day apparel that
i'd love to show you let's do it i do
so jc this is our women's golf day
capsule collection
we have apparel as well as accessories
all branded
callaway titleist and foot so let's
break down what exactly is happening on
women's golf day what are you guys doing
here in the store yeah so on
june 1st for women's golf day from 4 to
6 p.m we will have prizes games and
refreshments
as well as giving away to our first few
guests a complimentary gift bag
i love it so let's say there's a lady
watching right now she wants to get into
golf but for some reason
she's hesitant what advice do you have
for her not to be scared not to be
intimidated
actually the week of women's golf day we
will be having get golf ready which is a
six week program
which is a women's lesson clinic that
they can come in
and try and so they feel comfortable
stacy with this full outfit i feel like
i'm ready for the pga tour
is the best way to close it see if i can
make the putt let's do it i think you
can here we go
that's the way you end this segment
thank you stacy air high five all right
i appreciate it
all right women's golf day is june 1st
and the pga tour superstore is the
official retail sponsor
so june 1st from 4 to 6 p.m there will
be a social hour at every store
10 percent off exclusions apply they got
refreshments games prizes
sweepstakes and more mercedes